des kilomètres de poussière aux portes
de new delhi ici les routes s'étendent à
perte de vue le terrain de jeu des
motards en été il ne fait jamais moins
de 40 degrés sur le bitume indien sortir
les bécanes dans cette chaleur moite
c'est la balade du dimanche pour ces
jeunes français
le chiot
[Musique]
valentin est arrivé à delhi il y a
quatre ont à peine sortie d'école son
diplôme d'architecte en poche
dont la bande ils sont designers
ingénieurs chefs de projet
de ma journée
arrivé à new delhi au hasard des
opportunités professionnelles ils sont
vite tombés amoureux de cette ville
insolite il ya un truc qui m'a un peu
marqué c'est le un peu
grand mot mais espèce de liberté qu'on a
que faire de tout ce qu'on veut comme
conclure à moto avoir permis c'est
vivant et chaleureux c'est c'est
chaotique mais m'est agréable à chaque
carrefour à chaque tournant sébastien tu
as croisé tu peux croiser un énorme
embouteillage juste cause et par deux
pauvres vaches étudie mais on est où là
et personne ne veut les pousser une
expression qui dit que ce soit on vient
delicious
on en repart on our cema 7 à plozévet
un peu fou mais pas assez inconscient
pour se passer du kit élémentaires de
survie sur les routes indiennes
pourquoi le masque
pour la pollution et la poussière ici il
n'ya pas trop ce qu ils sont aujourd'hui
risque pour la cruciale pas très
agréable pour la journée les rues du
caire
[Musique]
la jungle de new delhi 10 millions de
véhicules en circulation
deux mille cinq cents nouvelles
immatriculations chaque jour difficile
de se frayer un chemin dans ce chaos
urbain
ces peurs attentes et
va jamais regardé derrière
permit pas de rétro tous les dimanches
c'est le même goût de l'aventuré qui
conduit valentin jusqu'au coeur de
délits au pied de la porte de l'inde on
a plus de 6500 kilomètres de la france
délit est une ville millénaire en
perpétuel mouvement une pieuvre
tentaculaire à 40 km du nord au sud en
en quelques années c'est devenu la
deuxième ville la plus peuplée de la
planète 30 millions d'habitants venus
des quatre coins de l'inde et du monde
pas toujours facile de se sentir chez
soi dans cette ville saturée de bruits
et d'odeurs tristement célèbre pour ses
nuage de pollution mais pour ceux qui
ont la patience d'apprivoiser la ville
deliessche ses livres et ses plus douce
merveille dans un pays en pleine
croissance la capitale indienne en
regorge de promesses une chance à saisir
pour les français qui s'y sont installés
comme cécile et son mari américain peter
ils ont lancé leur marque de vêtements
il ya cinq ans et se sont fait leur
place dans le monde du luxe indien oui
des lycées une pop ou mot à la mode en
là où la famille de veau et ses trois
adolescents ils s'installent et vont
vivre leur toute première rentrée en la
tradition dans la famille c'est chaque
rentrée scolaire ils ont leur petite
photo
la première photo indienne mais délit
attire aussi les jeunes en quête
d'exotisme comme valentin l'architecte
d'intérieur ou louise une expatriée
française fraîchement débarquée qui doit
construire son nouveau quotidien c'est
une ville qui n'est pas facile à saisir
à comprendre et un chaos hier à dompter
certainement pas
indomptables c'est tout le piment de
délits cette ville qui tient en haleine
la cité de tous les possibles
à quelques jours de leur toute première
rentrée scolaire en ondes l'heure est
aux préparatifs pour la famille de vaud
aujourd'hui la priorité de baptiste
l'aîné c'est de se faire beau pour le
lycée tu fais la coiffure thierry henry
non la famille s'est installée à delhi
il ya six mois et pour les ados baptiste
saison thimothée 15 ans et géraldine 13
ans difficile de retrouver ses habitudes
dans cette ville chaotique
guidés par le chauffeur hugues le père
de famille embarque les enfants dans ce
salon de beauté à l'indienne au premier
coup d'oeil pas de quoi rassurer les
trois ados ballet à toi
baptiste intrépide passe aux mains du
coiffeur qui commence en sans prévenir à
coups de tondeuse on me l'a pas demandé
si vous voulez donc le coiffeur et
allemand
j'espère qu'il va avoir la boule à zéro
ouai c'est trop bien hossa en france 1
tous les coiffeurs de france mais que ça
dans vos salons
toute la famille était un peu stressé à
l'idée de venir s'installer à delhi
c'est la maman estelle qui a été envoyée
ici pour le compte d'une grande
entreprise d'énergie les autres ont
suivi
à côté le tandem on vivait en fait dans
un village de montagne hélas est passé
de 40 chartreuse à new delhi c'est vrai
que c'est le gros gap et donc oui j'ai
ressenti de la peur au début la peur de
ne pas réussir à à m'adapter
c'est impressionnant
pour retrouver ses repères vivre à
l'occidentale quand on habite à new
delhi il faut se rendre à cannes markets
le marché des expatriés ici on trouve de
tout des baguettes des macarons ou du
chocolat et contrairement à beaucoup des
chops indienne ses boutiques acceptent
la carte bleue
c'est difficile de retenir du cash et
puis souvent les machines à cash y'a
plus rien plus rien dans l'axé là c'est
le cas c'est le cas en ce moment donc on
va essayer de tout régler avec la carte
bancaire il reste encore à remplir les
cartables hugues espère tous trouvés ici
on est dans la caverne d'ali baba de
cannes market j'ai l'impression
c'est le seul endroit où tu peux trouver
des feuilles comme ça
oui c'est sûr un bon business car si
l'homme ne coûte pas cher ça va être un
cérémonial incroyable ce normalement ici
il refait toute la mission tous les
produits importés sont lourdement taxés
par le gouvernement à l'addition était
fait super j'en ai pour 16 me 967
roupies ce qui fait 200 euros
addition salée pour les expats ce n'est
pas là que ce père de famille un sera
des économies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas facile de vivre ici à la française
tout ce qui arrive à new delhi découvre
vite qu'il faut s'accrocher pour trouver
ses marques dans cette ville monde à 26
ans elle aussi a décidé de faire le
grand saut
à peine débarqué louise est accueilli
par les trombes d'eau et la fournaise
les joies de la mousson indienne
dans ses valises tout est affaire pour
les deux prochaines années la jeune
française a tout quitté pour un poste à
l'ambassade de france
originaire de montpellier louise n'en
est pas à sa première expatriation
elle a déjà vécu au vietnam mais délit
c'est un autre visage de l'asie où la
misère vous frappe à chaque carrefour
c'est quel
contraste entre l'avion pour bien
prendre à travers le monde et ses avions
que des enfants vendons
alors qu'eux mêmes ont probablement
jamais pris l'avion dans lequel elle
à ces quelques images
[Musique]
et cela sans s'habitue en fait il faut
s'y habituer ou parler
on va voir ce qu'on va voir souvent
malgré un peu d'appréhension la jeune
femme est très excité à l'idée de
conquérir la capitale si une ville qui a
pas forcément bonne réputation mais en
fait quand on y vit on voit les aspects
de la ville et c'est finalement assez
agréable en tout cas c'était le cas à
saigon et
j'ai fait le pari en prenant ce poste
que ce sera la même chose a à d
louise avait déjà trouvé un logement
mais première surprise indienne le
propriétaire a changé d'avis la jeune
femme devra chercher un nouvel
appartement et dormir à l'hôtel cette
nuit
et parle de paille par le nom de l'hôtel
sur sur le bâtiment parce qu'ils disent
de regarder le nom du docteur gutjahr le
numéro 35
ça c'est de ce côté là
là c'est 78 146
ici dr gut a
déboussolé par cette numérotation sont
que ni tête trompait louise finit tout
de même par déposer ses bagages et
retrouve enfin un peu de réconfort et de
fraîcheur
[Musique]
ici
je ça c'est le ventilo
dès demain louise devra se mettre en
quête d'un appartement
la famille de vos elle a décidé de
s'installer à l'est de délits toute la
ville est organisée par bloc des zones
résidentielles sous surveillance les
deux veaux ont choisi ce quartier french
colonies traduisait le quartier des amis
une bulle de tranquillité où ils se sont
recréés un petit niche dans cette maison
[Applaudissements]
bon bah bienvenue à la maison donc ça
c'est notre havre de paix où
vous voyez
tout est possible on peut trouver une
maison française à annuler deux nuits
une maison presque française pour un
loyer digne de paris près de 3000 euros
par mois pour 200 m²
une des premières choses qu'on a fait en
arrivant c'est la création de
moustiquaires dans des lits il ya
malheureusement souvent des moustiques
et ça
c'est bien de pouvoir être au calme et
les protégés de pelle premiers jo était
horrible j'ai pas trop réussi à dormir
parce qu'il y avait trop de moustiques
mais maintenant ça va mieux possible
avec toute la moustiquaire et tout ça
gare au moustique tigre à delhi on
recense près de 15000 cas de dengue tous
les ans
mais une fois les précautions prises
la famille a aussi découvert le confort
de la vie en inde
chauffeur hommes de maisons jardiniers
cuisiniers et gardien six personnes les
accompagnent au quotidien et partage
tout de la vie de la maison
on était en france cet été et donc dans
nos bagages on a ramené peut-être que
ceux ci sont
là que tout est bâti fut le cas
les changes n'est pas toujours
concluants
dans ce pays où la majorité de la
population est végétarienne
[Rires]
[Musique]
plaisir on désespérait
j'ai pas vu le temps passer
estelle la maman travaille tard le soir
elle ne rentre jamais avant 20 heures
alors ce soir ces dîners indien préparé
par kamal
pour elle c'est le luxe de pouvoir se
mettre les pieds sous la table et
découvrir les spécialités locales
c'est non et c'est plein de cd nouveaux
légumes ou des en tout cas beaucoup de
légumes vous
c'est comme du pain d'après la source de
vos voeux des haricots des cha pâti en
guise de baguettes de pain pour les
enfants c'est une expérience culinaire
ces prochaines années ils vont devoir
s'habituer à manger beaucoup de riz et
des pis
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la ville louise est
maintenant au coeur de save d'art joung
un quartier d'expatriés situé à quelques
minutes des ambassades c'est là qu'elle
aimerait s'installer
mais louise va vite découvrir que
cherchait un appartement hollande est un
vrai périple en
ce matin elle a rendez vous pour une
visite
l'homme de lagence est heureux de lui
présenter ce salon richement meublé est
tapissé
c'est l'évacuation de la clim
oui parce que
ok
chaque nouvelle pièce est un peu plus
riche en surprises pour la jeune femme
alors ça c'est cassé mais il y en aura
bientôt un autre
oui ce sera réparé cette prime est
cassée mais y en aura une autre
toutes les chambres ont leur salle de
bain privée digne de cet appartement
demain tout sera propre
et
tout à réparer tout à nettoyer pour 900
euros de loyer par mois louise a du mal
à y croire on a un peu l'impression
qu'il ya des gens qui sont partis en
urgence et à même ses remix entre partis
en urgence et inhabitée depuis deux ans
et
oui on se sent pas vraiment prêt à
s'installer devant
avec un budget de 1000 euros par mois
louise espère quand même trouvé mieux
quitte à enchaîner les visites jusqu'à
trouver la perle rare
la vie à delhi s'étend jusque sur les
toits de la ville un lieu de
convivialité de repos ou de travail
depuis neuf ans eux essaient de se faire
leur place au sommet
cécile et peter d'ascoli une française
un américain un couple de créateurs de
mode depuis quelques années leurs
marques de vêtements
est devenu une référence en inde
aujourd'hui cécile prépare le lancement
de sa prochaine collection d'été et
veille à ce que tout soit parfait
[Musique]
toutefois porter les vêtements tu vois
ses 58 des voix sur un raki c'est une
chose mais quand tu les vois portée
c'est là que
je sais que tu as bien travaillé et a vu
juste dans les couleurs dans les formes
l'aboutissement de trois mois de travail
et de plusieurs années à s'imposer dans
le luxe indien
les coulisses de la mode se cachent dans
les entrepôts de faridabad à près d'une
heure de route au sud de la ville
c'est ici que cécile et peter ont
installé leurs ateliers il y a 6 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore fait imprimer quête 1 et cat
toute son inspiration
cécile la puise dans la culture indienne
les broderies et les motifs
traditionnels locaux c'est mon maroc
sochaux prochain une histoire d'amour
avec la mode et avec la ville de new
delhi c'est une grande histoire j'ai
rencontré mon mari si donc je sais pas à
l'époque même quand on s'est mariés
qu'on allait vivre ici mais
[Musique]
c'est pas anodin donc c'est une belle
histoire
mais l'histoire
encore à goès poujade en stand by side
ou gerbe
avant de sortir hors garde toujours en
haut y'a pas des sages
ils viennent boire l'eau de la clean et
parfois ils essayent de rentrer dans le
studio parce qu'ils savent qu'il y avait
à cuisiner
jabil attaque once
on les connaît quand elle est arrivée
crée l'entreprise n'a pris que quelques
semaines
saupoudrage poids d'un jogging today ce
qui a pris un peu plus de temps c'est de
s'entourer d'employés prêts à travailler
à l'occidentale on les a formés pour que
puisse travailler comme à paris deal
avec des nos clients qui sont à paris
qui sont à new york
au japon par exemple
[Musique]
member du team c'est pas toujours facile
parce que quand elles se marient les
jeunes pas les prix il faut quand même
toujours l'autorisation du mari est
revenu à travailler c'est toujours un
peu risqué d'embauché d'état parce que
s'ils n'arrivent pas dans le travail
ça permettant d'employer
au total 16 personnes travaillent ici à
plein temps avec des salaires qui
s'échelonnent de 200 à 1000 euros par
mois
une main d'oeuvre bon marché ce qui
permet à cécile et peter de faire broder
tous leurs vêtements à la main
[Musique]
des traditions qui se transmettent de
génération en génération
aujourd'hui grâce à ce savoir faire leur
marque est distribuée dans plus d'une
trentaine de pays
[Musique]
vivre à new delhi c'est accepter de
traverser le concert des klaxons et les
kilomètres d'embouteillages quotidien
dès 9 heures va longtemps est coincé
dans les bouchons alors comme tout le
monde ici sa journée de travail commence
dans la voiture
plus d'une heure de route aujourd'hui le
jeune architecte d'intérieur a rendez
vous dans un des quartiers de la
banlieue sud
du regard le centre financier de délits
c'est un peu le quartier parisien de la
défense à la sauce indienne des tours
modernes qui en quelques années ont
poussé au milieu des champs
[Musique]
la société française qui emploie
valentin a signé de nombreux contrats
sur le marché immobilier de gurgaon en
tant que chef designer le jeune français
bien surveiller l'avancement de ce
chantier les futurs bureaux d'une
multinationale japonaise
la structure est 100% prête
c'est un nouveau tuyau pour la
protection incendie
oui c'est l'ancien ils vérifient que
chaque détail est conforme au plan qu'il
a dessinée ça c'est la vue de la
réception avec ici on le devine la
courbe qui est en partie supérieure est
les hawks
valentin a dû apprendre à gérer les
imprévus indien
couple en est
là où comme l'électricité qui n'en fait
qu'à sa tête alléluia
c'est celle là il faut se débrouiller
ouais ouais qui porte un nom d'ailleurs
qui fortin prononcé avec mon accent
français mais qui le giugale et on le
dit souvent c'est c'est presque un sport
national c'est faire avec les moyens du
bord c'est se débrouiller c'est la
débrouillardise les petites astuces
indienne valentin va encore on découvrir
aujourd'hui
voilà l'utilisation peu commune d'un
casque de chantier dans cette bétonneuse
à même le sol
c'est une première pour moi prendre un
quinze qui traîne c'est un récipient
comme un autre sur la tête ça doit être
embêtant
du coup le clou et je viens de la
découvrir ça valait pas mal en inde ça
coûte plus cher de louer un marteau
piqueur pendant une journée que de payer
trois indiens accroupi ont cassé bitume
c'est c'est normal de les voir accroupi
de casser le casser le béton
voilà ils font comme ça il pourra la
main il faut à l'ancienne en quatre ans
les projets de valentin se sont
multipliés il en supervise près d'une
soixantaine cette année une opportunité
incroyable pour ce jeune architecte
d'intérieur avec là on voit au loin
arrivé à delhi à peine sortie d'école la
ville est devenue son terrain de jeu on
voit toutes ces tours d'hélice est temps
comme ça un peu de manière tentaculaire
sur la périphérie et les campagnes
hier il ya du boulot il ya du boulot il
ya des opportunités
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
à paris j'aurais mis des années avant de
pouvoir faire ce que je fais maintenant
là malgré mon jeune âge sa pause on va
dire pas beaucoup de problèmes
face aux clients je peux je peux faire
un petit peu que je veux en termes de
design alors qu'en france on était
beaucoup plus compliquée à
gravir les échelons à vitesse éclair
dont la ville de tous les possibles
il suffit d'un peu de détermination pour
ouvrir toutes les portes même les plus
inattendus
[Applaudissements]
il est bientôt minuit valentin et ses
amis ont rendez vous au sommet de cet
immeuble en appartements dont l'adresse
est gardée secrète
ce soir c'est l'anniversaire de ce riche
entrepreneur
dans ce grand penthouse ont
régulièrement lieu soirée événement
quand la jeunesse dorée indienne se
réunit dans le secret de la nuit et pour
être de la partie il faut connaître les
bonnes personnes
ambiance tamisée pour cet anniversaire
très sélect une trentaine d'invités
trois dj une piscine de ce toit qui
domine la ville le son des platines va
résonner toute la nuit
la fraîcheur du jacuzzi sous les étoiles
voilà de quoi faire rêver nos jeunes
français
qui fait qu'on reste en effet un groupe
stable à ces lieux ouverts il n'y a pas
de barrière à partir du moment où tu
fais l'effort de venir en inde
personne ne peut être jugé sur deux
souvient de quelle région des états qui
fait plaisir c'est de pouvoir parler à
des gens de différentes classes sociales
et 3 échangé parce qu'on est tous là
dans le même bateau on fait tous la même
manière c'est moins le cas à paris
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la ville c'est une
autre nuit indienne qui bat son plein
celle des traditions millénaires ce soir
c'est l'anniversaire de krishna le dieu
de tous les dieux dans la religion
hindoue louise est venu assister au
spectacle accompagné d'un de ses
nouveaux collègues de l'ambassade sur la
scène des pas de danse et frais niche ou
rythme de l'harmonium
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et joyeux
toute la soirée jusqu'à tard le
lendemain les croyants déposent des
fleurs et de petites statuettes en
offrande même s'ils sont étrangers nos
deux français reçoivent eux aussi une
bénédiction
[Applaudissements]
j'en donnais d'abord une but de donner
un peu fermenté et ensuite du sucre
[Musique]
d
ébéniste ouais c'est ça il y à plus de
30 millions de dieux en inde difficile
de s'y retrouver au milieu des tableaux
de la vie de krishna c'est une carnation
et ses emblèmes
connaît très mal en conçoit
les représentations de divinités il y en
a dans tous les restaurants dans
beaucoup de lieux dans les dents des
taxis dans les rixes chaud j'ai
l'impression que ça une place beaucoup
plus importante dans la vie des indiens
que ça me peut avoir dans la vie
quotidienne en france
et de manière plus festive aussi et
comme beaucoup de couleurs beaucoup de
lumière
les représentations sont colorés ces
danses abris et les paillettes il
pompon et des fleurs ces fêtes qui
rythme la vie de délits
louisot se promet de toujours y assister
elle qui aimeraient s'intégrer dans
cette ville où tout lui échappe
trois semaines après son arrivée dans le
quartier de save d'argeles elle a
finalement trouvé un appartement ce
matin enfin la jeune femme va pouvoir
déposer ses valises chez elle
déménagement à pied escorté par les
garçons de l'hôtel je resserre de
variantes 500 m pendant trois semaines
le cas c'est très sympa donc j'avais
envie de rester ici et je suis contente
d'avoir trouvé un appartement à
proximité
sa recherche d'appartement s'est
transformé en véritable chasse au trésor
elle n'y croyait plus
alors les clés en main c'est le
soulagement
on a dû faire une quinzaine de visites
en tout je pense pour trouver un
appartement avec plusieurs agents
différents les premiers ont commencé à
nous montrer à la fin des appartements
qui correspondait pas du tout à nos
critères donc je pense qu'il est un peu
désespéré on a changé d'agent et on a
trouvé suis là donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle on a réussi à trouver en trois
semaines ce qui est assez correcte mais
qui paraît long quand même quand on est
à l'hôtel pendant tout le week-end
pictures of the flat and thank you so
fun le dépositoire emilie fouilles aux
smp qst comme perroquet fait trois
chambres 150 m² pour un peu moins de
1000 euros par mois une bonne affaire
pour lui
c'est un peu vide ils font encore meublé
et décoré
nous manque un drap les bombes des
oreillers et des rideaux des assiettes
découvert le dévers et puis mais sinon
ça commence déjà à ressembler un petit
peu comme un appartement
deux ou trois courses sont donc
nécessaires avant sa première nuit
pas très compliqué de trouver de petites
échoppes à deux pas de chez elle en
revanche en inde il n'existe pas
d'hypermarchés
ya pas une boutique dans laquelle on
peut tout trouver donc pour acheter des
légumes des fruits des assiettes
début du coton et je ne sais quoi il
faut aller dans quatre magasins
différents donc il faut savoir qu'ils
vont quoi
et là y'a des langues
ici je pense que la plupart des légumes
poussent avec énormément énormément de
pesticides c'est pas du tout les mêmes
normes qu'en europe donc effectivement
je sais pas exactement quelle est la
qualité des produits qui alors dans ce
magasin est un collectionneur renseigner
louise se passera donc de fruits pour la
soirée
mais difficile de faire son
lave-vaisselle
et avant six mois les soins
[Applaudissements]
et
qui
soit aujourd'hui pour aujourd'hui ça
fera la faire et puis on trouvera des
choses un peu mieux quand on aura un peu
plus de temps de comprendre où on achète
de la vaisselle dans cette ville là
probablement plein d'endroits mais on
les connaît pas encore patienter
déterminer louis c'est qu'elle a encore
au moins deux ans pour découvrir tous
les bons plans de la capitale
en des bons plans incontournable pour
les expatriés hughes va le découvrir
très vite
pour la première fois il commande un
produit illicite entendent livrer
secrètement à domicile dans ce sac
quelques kilos d'une viande intouchable
la vache sacrée indienne
[Applaudissements]
elles ont lieu ici l'abattage des vaches
est passible de 10 ans de prison alors
les vendeurs restent dans l'ombre
historiquement le boeuf est un animal
sacré donc
peut pas le manger et effectivement dans
la loi on ne mange pas de buffy si on
fait appel à un dealer de boeuf
c'est via le circuit des expatriés c'est
vrai qu'on n'est on n'est pas encore
passé devenu végétarien
[Rires]
de quoi faire pour la rentrée
je n'ai eu à part un petit circuit
parallèle
le plein de protéines de quoi motiver un
peu les ados qui rêvent de steak et
d'entre eux coûtent
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée des classes
pour géraldine la benjamine de la
famille à plus de 6500 km de ses amies
françaises
mais pour ne pas être trop dépaysés ces
expatriés ont importé quelques petites
coutume familiale depuis qu'ils sont en
maternelle la tradition dans la famille
c'est chaque rentrée scolaire ils ont
leurs petites photos et la première
photo indienne noël
cette année géraldine on entre en
cinquième à l'école française de délits
ici il n'ya pas plus de 300 élèves de la
maternelle au lycée à peine une
vingtaine dans la classe de géraldine
alors que faire ce jeu vous a mené par
ordre alphabétique jeu sera plus simple
que de faire des va et vient dans les
machines comme emploi du temps bien
chargé jusque là ça ne change pas de la
france
le sport un petit peu trop choquante une
propulsion et d'alerté
on a tout le temps chaud contre va
après yann où elle est à faire en hiver
une pollution fermé soir on n'a pas de
réécrire au dos mais les matches
les masques de pollution masque
obligatoire pendant les pics de
pollution respirer l'air de délit serait
comme fumer 50 cigarettes par jour
l'école a même dû s'équiper d'une
soixantaine de filtres r okla vous en
avez par contre dans le gymnase
j'envoie un deux trois 3 purificateurs
d'air et même machine
le comité de gestion de l'école qui est
constituée par des parents 2 lésine pas
sur ses investissements parce que c'est
la santé deux enfants thé
allez c'est parti malgré ces contraintes
l'école organise de nombreuses activités
jusque dans la cour de récré occupée par
les danses bollywood et les sessions de
yoga des élèves de tous horizons une
quarantaine de nationalités ici on parle
dans toutes les langues et on danse sur
tous les rythmes ans
[Applaudissements]
une fois les enfants déposer à l'école
hugues remonte vers la vieille ville au
nord de delhi toutes les semaines il
donne de son temps dans le quartier de
mortiers à cannes l'un des bidonvilles
les plus pauvres de la ville
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il est venu distribuer du
lèche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mendiants enfants des rues ici les gens
vivent avec moins de 2 euros par jour
une pauvreté extrême impossible pour
hugues de rester indifférent
c'est vrai que moi je suis quand même le
roi du pétrole et à ma femme qui
travaille mon salaire chauffeurs qui
sont les enfants donc je ne peux pas
rien faire je peux pas être oisifs moi
ça malheureux
dont cet appartement une trentaine
d'enfants déscolarisés g viennent chaque
mercredi apprendre à lire écrire par les
indie anglais les deux langues
officielles du pays
pour le moment est facile couru de
communiquer en hindi je connais namasté
chokri ya
non
tic ethic et moi je suis nul en longue
donc déjà l'alphabet psychologiquement
mais bon j'ai joué je vais essayer de
parler un petit peu quelques quelques
mots mais
mais voilà j'ai du boulot là dessus et
il va falloir réussir à dépasser cette
barrière psychologique mais on va y
aller rendez vous dans trois
cantons via daily il y a toujours des
situations où par les quelques mots
d'hindi peut s'avérer indispensable
valentin est en repérage pour un de ses
chantiers son client cherche une
demi-douzaine de tapis pour habiller ses
nouveaux bureaux dans ce marché à ciel
ouvert plus de 80 étals où les artisans
venus des quatre coins de l'inde
proposent leurs créations
de mingan sa c 4 mètres sur six
va longtemps négocié toujours les prix
30% moins cher et pour bien s'entendre
dans un pays où la négociation est un
sport national mieux vaut connaître
quelques mots d'hindi
ya les indispensables le primordial à
delhi en inde c4 n'a donc combien
combien donc c'est pour tout le tuk-tuk
riccio ici les tapis bon pour tous
combien il y a
tomates aulaqi et
moyen moyen qui a un éboulis ninon est
ce que tu es content tu peux faire mieux
que la toile
à chaque nouveau vendeur de tapis
valentin étals sont modestes vocabulaire
avec assurance quatre mâles
et voilà
fayçal ben fahd ben fayçal fajr est ça
fait du
60 70 balle
file à 10,40
alors mis au goût de 10 quand
6800 roupies place price
nous voir clairement n'est pas d'ici
dont qui il traîne une marche
supplémentaire de la première étape
c'est déjà de mettre peut-être appris
d'indiens et après de négocier à
l'indienne c'est-à-dire très très dur ça
marche aussi pour les rites chose
c'est-à-dire bac vous tu me fais pas ce
prix là et ben ok je m'en vais je vais
voir son ton copain à côté
et au général rappelle ce jour là
valentin rentrer bredouille il attend un
véritable coup de coeur pour finaliser
ce projet qu'il suit depuis des mois
le chantier est presque terminée 600 m²
de bureaux dont valentin à dessiner
chaque détail
il reste encore quelques finitions bien
sûr mais les employés sont déjà dans
leurs fauteuils
deux glaces et doit respecter
c'est une petite fierté ouais c'est
quand on connaît les difficultés de se
payer à réaliser des choses propres à
compter ou
c'est compliqué mais je vais y arriver
et et du coup je vais prouver que c'est
possible
donc ça c'est un peu
satisfaction personnelle encore un
challenge à relever pour va longtemps
l'inauguration des bureaux aura lieu
dans moins d'un mois
dans sa maison du sud de delhi cécile se
prépare pour un autre genre de chantier
elle est invitée un événement d'un grand
magazine de mode vogue india pour la
créatrice c'est une bonne opportunité de
promouvoir sa marque
d'oreille avec du turquoise pour aller
avec ma robe on va rencontrer la
rédactrice en chef c'est c'est
une occasion de la voir aller sur bombay
donc et de parler de notre travail c'est
cultiver des relations avec la presse
d'aller à ce genre d'événement la
dernière parce qu'on a eu dans vogue
c'est qui concerne notre marque on est
plus c'est sûr dans le radar ici de la
presse que à l'étranger ou où la
concurrence entre marquer bien plus
importante et on n'a même pas besoin de
payer pour ça c'est l'un des événements
les plus réputés du monde de la mode à
delhi le salon du mariage de vos guides
ya 500 exposants aux créations les plus
extravagantes robes brodées de pierres
précieuses des pièces à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros un monde du
luxe et du glamour ou peter et cécile
ont construit tout leur réseau
ici il côtoie les plus grands couturiers
indien
ces deux mille heures de travail
c'est un lac ses feuilles flottent à la
surface en moyenne les indiens dépensent
15000 euros pour la cérémonie de mariage
mais dans l'élite indienne le budget n'a
pas de limite
au coeur du salon une réception privée
ambiance décontractée et informel cécile
et peter en profite pour se vendre
auprès de la rédactrice en chef du
magazine et ça marche
j'adore c'est qu'elles font oui c'est
super
j'adorerais venir voir
je vais t'envoyer un message pour qu'on
vient de te voir toutes les deux demain
je retourne à ma réunion
socialement ici on rencontre des gens
donc c'est stimulant pour notre travail
pour une prime à vue elle le dit joël tt
robe l avenir demain à la maison sauf
que je fais rarement mais pour priver
pari réussi pour le couple
franco-américain dans quelques semaines
la photo de cécile et peter sera de
nouveau dans les pages du magazine
indien
l'avantagent pour ceux qui vivent à dei
c'est de pouvoir s'échapper pour pas
cher dans la région voisine du rajasthan
à moins d'une heure en avion voici
udaipur la venise de l'orient et ses
palais de maharadjahs
pour hugues et estelle les parents de la
famille de vos
retrouvailles en amoureux pour se
remettre des émotions de la rentrée
nous avons été l'avocat du barreau là
bas
deux batteurs sur la maman et la petite
fille tu te rends compte pour 30 euros
et dans un petit palais et ouais c'est
un petit un bon dépaysement et on
pouvait pas s'offrir sa nos enfants sont
possibles trop cher
à une heure de délire où on arrive à se
trouver un petit lieu paradisiaque plus
de tranquillité kaka délit aussi à delhi
en inde cette excitation mais après on
est content de couper pour pour les
8èmes chacune de leur escapade est une
nouvelle évasion ambiance calme et
mystique sur udaipur il découvre l'un
des coins les plus romantiques de l'inde
qui mord au bord du lac dans un palais
centenaire les deux amoureux vont
s'installer pour un dîner aux chandelles
tête à tête dans un décor de rêve
français
à ta santé chéri à nous à toi surtout
et alors c'est un pays avec une culture
incroyable
incroyablement compliqué donc on
on sait pas s'il va dans les sept mois
déjà passés c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas
compris grand chose je suis pas sûr que
même après trois ans comprendra
davantage mais ça développe la curiosité
pas forcément et ça c'est une démarche
qui est aussi je trouve très
rajeunissantes pour pour nous et puis
surtout les enfants qui au départ
ne voulait pas entendre parler de l'un
d'eux débit préféré rester en france et
tout ça y est ici on fait quoi et
timothée et nous a dit pas sûr que dans
trois ans rentre en france quoi donc
c'est ces intégrations réussies
des lits l'un des ses splendeurs hughes
et estelle à s'y sentent maintenant chez
eux et les changerait leur place pour
rien au monde
[Musique]